اعتراض الطائرتان عسكريتان بريطانيه
والمانيه مقاتله روسيه بعد دخولها المجال
الاستوني التابع لحلف النيتو تاتي الحادثه
بعيده اعلاني وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن
فقدان مسيره امريكيه بعد اصطدام مقاتله
الروسيه بها فوق البحر الاسود وقدمت
واشنطن وموسكو روايتين مختلفتين لما وقع
وصفه تحذيرات من مخاطر احتكاك مباشر بين
روسيا والغرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا لنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
اي سياق دولي وسياسي جاءت فيه رسائل
التصعيد الميداني والاحتكاك العسكري
المباشر بين الغرب وروسيا وما هي احتمالات
انزلاق الامور الى مواجهه عسكريه اوسع
كيف تنعكس هذه الرسائل على مسار الحرب في
اوكرانيا وعلى المشهدين الاقليمي والدولي
كذلك ما هي فرص واحتواء التصعيد المتبادل
والوصول الى تفاهمات تحول دون تفاقم
الازمه عسكريا
[موسيقى]
بين حادثتين الاحتكاك مباشر واندلاع
مواجهه بين روسيا والدول الغربيه مسافه
يدركها حتى اولئك الذين لم يتوقفوا عن
التحذير من حرب قد تضع الطرفين وجها لوجه
تحذيرات ارتفعت وتيرتها بشده منذ اندلاع
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والتي اضحت فيها
كييف محور حرب غير مباشره بين موسكو
والعواصم الغربيه وبين نبره تصعيدا واخرى
للتهدئه يرشح مراقبون هذه الاحتكاكات
لتطورات لاحقه وفي انتظار ذلك يقول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان حادثه
المسيره كان متهورا وغير امن ويجب التحقيق
بشانه في المقابل يقول وزير الخارجيه
ان اي حوادث يمكن ان تتطور لمواجهه بين
دولتين نوويتين
مخاطره ولا يمكن للامريكيين الا يدركوا
ذلك
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو
فيكتور
وهو المحلل السياسي والخبير في الشؤون
الدوليه من نيويورك معنى مايلز كاجنز عضو
في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه الامريكيه في
مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
ومن الدوحه معنى العميد الياس حناء الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بكم جميعا ضيوفا فيما
وراء الخبر ابدا معك كلاميد الياس حنا
بالامس فقط كنا نتحدث عن اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه اليوم نتحدث عن استهداف طائره
روسيه
ما اهميه ما الذي تحمله هذه التحركات في
سياق ما يجري طبعا في اوكرانيا
ليلى اعتراض الطائرات الروسيه ان كان على
حدود دول النيتو او حتى فوق بحر البلطيق
هذا امر كان روتينيا ويتكرر وهناك نمط له
اهداف متعدده خاصه من الجهه الروسيه ولكن
اليوم يتحدث ونرى ان الحرب هي بالواسطه
كما تفضلت وقلت في المقدمه انها حرب
الواسطه يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
روسيا يتقاتلان على الساحه الاوكرانيه
والغرب من جهه وروسيا من جهه اخرى حادثه
المسيره هي نقلت مستوى النقاش او التماس
الى الاحتكاك المباشر بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبين روسيا هذا الامر
قد يذهب الى لا يحسب عقباه ولكن ايضا هو
ينقلنا الى مرحله مرحله جديده من الصراع
يعني بالحد الادنى يجب اعاده رسم قواعد
الاشتباك بين الولايات الامريكيه وبين
روسيا وليس بالضروره ان نذهب الى حرب
شامله وكامله لماذا لانه المخاطر الكبيره
وهناك خطوط حمراء وضعت من قبل الرئيس
بايدن في بدايات الحرب ومن قبل الرئيس
بوتين ايضا في بدايات الحرب خاصه موضوع
الانتقال الى المستوى الاعلى او السلاح
النووي حادثه المسيره هي حدث تورنيك بوينت
كما يقال نقطه تحول تاتي الى مرحله جديده
تقول ظروف الحرب في اوكرانيا ظروف خرسون
ظروف
شبه جزيره قرم واهميه اهميتها للرئيس
بوتين وهي سترسم قواعد اشتباك جديده قد
تكون مباشره وقد تكون عبر الاتفاق الضمني
قواعد اشتباك جديده بلا شك سيد كاغنسه
تعتمد ايضا على الطريقه التي تقرا فيها
واشنطن الرساله التي حدثت بسبب اسقاط
مسيرتها وما تق راه في ثناياها
مساء الخير مساء النور اهلا
الولايات المتحده قد اوضحت ومن خلال
التصريحات واضحه من البيت الابيضات دفاع
هل تنتاكرون ووزاره الخارجيه انها تدين
طريقه التحليق غير الامنه للطيارين الروس
والتي تمخضت عن تحطم
المسيره الامريكيه الى البحر الاسود لكن
هذا ليس تصعيدا من جانب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وحلف النيتو والتدخلهما في ازمه اوكرانيا
ولكن من الاهميه بمكان للقاده في موسكو
ان هذه الامور
ويتواصلان بشانها عبر القنوات الدبل
وماسيه لتفادي ايه اخطاء في الحسابات
والدخول في حاله من الصدام المباشر
ولكن حتى يحصل ذلك لابد من ان نفهم يعني
مجرى الرساله بين الطرفين بالامس سيد
لطوفكن كان هناك انطباع بان اسقاط المسيره
الى حد ما شفى الروس وربما رفع حتى من
شعبيه بوتين اليوم يتم اسقاط طائره روسيه
او استهدافها ما الذي يعنيه هذا وما الذي
ينعكس على روسيا وعلى شعبيه بوتين ايضا
في البدايه
الطائرات الحربيه البريطانيه والالمانيه
التي كانت
تقوم بقياده
طائرتنا
والسفينه الحربيه في البحر البلطيق
حتى
كانوا يقوموا بتوصيل هذه الطائره لم
يقوموا بالتعرض لها تعرض لها يعني خطفها
او تدميرها ان الطيران بجوار هذه الطائره
شيء طبيعي للتاكد
من وصول الطائره الى طريقها الصحيح ولم
تكن هذه طائرات عسكريه بل طائرات
من نوع اخر
وكان في البدايه هناك اعلان منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ان لدى هذه
الطائرات الحق في التحليق في تلك المواقع
وعندما كانت طائرات تدخل لترى
عندما كانت تتفقد الطائره المسيره الطائره
التي كان من الممكن ان تحمل صواريخ
جو جو او ممكن ان تحمل قنابل ثقيله او
ربما معدات رادارات استخباراتيه او انظمه
دفاع راداريه وعندما اقتربت الطائرات
لتفتيش والتاكد من هذه
المسيره عندها قام سائق المسيره
بمحاوره فاشله ادت لوقوع الطائره في الماء
ولم نمس هذه المسيره اذا قمنا بمس
لكانت الطائرات الروسيه مدمره ايضا جزئيا
على الاقل ولكنه طائراتنا عادت
لمواقعها سليمه ما الذي نستنتجه
الامريكيين يستطيعون ان يقولوا ما يريدون
ولكن عليهم ان لا يقتربوا الى حدودنا اذا
قاموا بنقد حدودنا سوف يحدث معهم ما حدث
مع المسيره تماما لذلك يجب ان يحترموا
اجواء الدول او المناطق التابعه لنا
وعندها لن يكون هناك اي حوادث غير جيده
العميد الياس حنا بالامس كنت تتحدث عن ان
طائرات الاكس موجوده اصلا في
المنطقه الاس يعني المهمات الاستطلاعيه
فلنقل بين قوسين لهذه الطائرات سواء من
الطرف الروسي او من الطرف الامريكي شيء
معتاد بين القوى العظمى ولكن اليس ايضا
صحيحا ان القيمه
الحقيقيه ليست في المعلومات التي تجمع هذه
الطائرات وما حصل من استهداف لها هو في
الواقع قيمته اكثر في ربما معرفه استعداد
الطرف الاخر
للمجاسفه والتصعيد
شبه جزيره قرم بالكامل بالتفاصيل وهذه
تعتبر تبوك او نقطه حمراء او منطقه ممنوعه
بالنسبه للرئيس بوتين لانها تعتبر
جوهره التاج في المشروع الاوكراني للرئيس
بوتين اثنين هناك دائما تحضيرات اوكرانيه
يتحدث عنها المسؤولون الاوكرانيون انه
يحضر لعمليه مهمه في نفس الوقت كانت تقصف
خرسون وهناك كانت عمليات عسكريه في خرسون
ومنهم من يقول ان المرحله القادمه هي
مرحله استعداد هجوم اوكرانيا للهجوم من
زبالوجيا باتجاه
وللوصول الى
حدود
شبه جزيره القرم الاهم ليله ايضا جزيره
قرمش تهدفت بعده احداث يعني اغراق السفينه
موسكو استهداف استهداف القواعد العسكريه
البريه او البحريه كما شابه ولكن اليوم
نحن في مرحله جديده من هنا يجب الانطلاق
هل ستذهب الى تصعيد كبير انا اعتقد هناك
دائما ضوابط لهذا الامر لانه الذهاب الى
حرب وحرب مباشره بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وروسيا امر بعد اعتقد الفريقان لا يريدون
هذا الامر يريدون هذا الامر
على العموم ونحن نتحدث تتواتر التصريحات
عن على اكثر من مستوى مثلا هناك بيانات
ملاحيه تتحدث عن طائرات استطلاع امريكيه
واوروبيه عسكريه تنشط منطقه البحر الاسود
هناك تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه
اعتبار ما حصل استفزاز وايضا التصريحات من
الجانب الامريكي واعود هنا اليك السيد
كاجنز تعتبر ان ما حدث ربما حتى بغير قصد
في جمله هذه التصريحات
والمختلفه في الواقع بعضها يتحدث عن عمل
مقصود واستفزاز والاخر يتحدث عن ربما خطا
غير مقصود الى اين يمكن ان تسير الامور
ليلى
ليلى ان الولايات المتحده سوف تستمر
بمساعده اوكرانيا من اجل الدفاع عن
اراضيها من الغزو الروسي وهو امر مثير
للاهتمام ان فيكتور ضيفنا الاخر قال ان
روسيا تريد الولايات المتحده ان تحترم
سياده وسلامه الاراضي التابعه لروسيا سبب
تدخل امريكا في هذا النزاع هو ان روسيا لا
ولم تحترم سياده اراضي والبلدان الاخرى
فلهذا السبب نحن سنتوقع من الولايات
المتحده ان تستمر بجمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه بطرق مختلفه عبر الاقمار
الاصطناعيه
المسيرات
وسائل التجسس الالكترونيه والتصوير
الفوتوغرافي
لكي تستطيع القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
الحصول على معلومات دقيقه في عملياتها ضد
القوات الروسيه الغازيه الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده ودول الناتو لا تريد
تصعيدا او حربا مباشره مع روسيا
ولكن السيد لتفكن في الوقت الذي ربما
تبدو الولايات المتحده وكانها تقلل من
اهميه ما يجري على الاقل على صعيد
التصريحات نسمع ما يقوله وزير الخارجيه
الروسي لهجه تصعيدا عندما يتحدث عن
استفزاز ويتحدث عن اي مواجهه بين قوتين
النوويتين
يمكن
يعني ان تشكل مخاطره ولا يمكن للامريكيين
الا يدركوا ذلك
انا اعتقد ان
تصعيد النداع ممكن يؤدي الى التوجه نووي
هذا فعلا كذلك واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
ليست مهتمه بهذا ولا تريد حرب مباشره مع
روسيا لانهم يفهمون ان روسيا لديها صواريخ
نوويه وهي دوله قويه وان هذا النزاع لن
ينتهي للولايات المتحده او لروسيا بنهايه
جيده
فلذلك الولايات المتحده وروسيا ايضا
سيحاولون ان لا يجعل الامور تصل الى هذا
النزاع فيما بينهم ولكن
عندما تقوم عندما يقوم احد الطرفين بالسير
على حد السكين
عندها الامور تؤدي الى
خطوره على الجميع احترام
سلامه الاراضي للدول الاخرى وعندها
عندما اسمع في الولايات المتحده ان روسيا
لا تحترم سلامه
الاراضي الاخره اذكر قصف امريكا
والهجمات في سوريا وفي افغانستان وفي
العراق وليبيا وكذا وهكذا ليست الولايات
المتحده من ممكن ان تعلم روسيا احترام
سلامه اعراض الدول هذا شيء غير اخلاقي اما
بالنسبه
النزاع بين دولتين عظيمتين هذا نداع محتمل
ويجب علينا ان نقوم بكل ما في وسعنا حتى
لا يحدث هذا العميد الياس حنا كنت تتحدث
عن تغيير في قواعد الاشتباك هل يمكن فعلا
ان تتطور الامور الى حرب ومواجهه نوويه
كما يذهب وزير الخارجيه ويحذر
منها وهل من اليه لتفادي هذه الاحتكاكات
واحتواء الموقف
انا اعتقد الموضوع النووي ليلى هو موضوع
معقد جدا هناك عقيد عقيده نبويه روسيه
تقول متى استعمال السلاح النووي عندما
تهدد وحده الاراضي الروسيه خاصه وحتى ولو
كانت من حرب تقليديه تدور على حدودها
اليوم دم ضم الاربعه اقاليم بالنسبه
للرئيس بوتين يعتبرها اراضي روسيه وهذا
امر يهدد الوحده الروسيه ولكن هذا الامر
الصين تقول لا باستعمال لا لاستعمال
النووي وهم حلفاء الرئيس بوتين الهند تقول
بلا اثنين يجب ان يكون هناك توازن بين
الهدف وبين الاستعمال لهذا السلاح يعني
انت اذا اردت ان تسيطر على اوكرانيا
ودمرتها بالنووي لا يمكن استغلال هذا
النصر اثنين يجب ان يكون الجيش الروسي
مجهز لحرب النوويه ثلاثه التفاعلات
الاسقاط الاشعاعات وما شابه وهذا امر
شهدته روسيه
رهيبه عندما تاثرت هي وبيلاروسيا اكثر من
غيرها اليوم هذه المرحله ليلى يقال عنها
بدراسه معهد للدراسات يقول ما يسمى
يعني اعطاء الرسائل
الاكراهيه يعني هذه الرساله باسقاط
المسيره هي اكثر من رساله عاديه لانها
تربط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مباشره
بالحرب الاوكرانيه ليثبت ما تقوله روسيه
ان امريكا التي تقاتل مباشره ولكن هي اقل
من حرب اساسيه هي حادث معين من ضمن صوره
اكبر قد يخلق لها قواعد اشتباك ولكن اليوم
المعركه الكبرى قد تكون في مخمور طيب قد
تكون في مالي توبول قد تكون في كوبيانس
هذا هو الامر كيف ستكون عليه حاله المعركه
على الساحه من سيربح من سيقوم بالهجوم متى
واين وكيف طيب السيد ولا يمكن فعلا
القرار الاخير بارسال الطائرات استطلاع
عسكريه امريكيه واوروبيه في منطقه البحر
الاسود الا يمكن فعلا ان يكون بمثابه صب
الزيت على النار الا يمكن النظر اليها من
هذه النقطه بدل من احتواء الموقف كما تذهب
بعد التصريحات
الولايات المتحده
تشغل طائرات
وسفن وفقا
لقوانين والاحكام الدوليه
للحروب وهذا كان مجالا جويا حرا حيث كانت
الطائره المسيره تحلق والتي تم فيها
اعتراضها بشكل
عدواني وغير امن من قبل الطيارين الروس
وهناك تقارير من
تبين بان الطيارين الروس اطلقوا الوقود من
طائراتهم باتجاه
المسيره هذا تصرف هذه المستايره تكلف 32
مليون دولار الان هي سقطت في البحر
الولايات المتحده لديها
من مثلها واتوقع من وزاره الدفاع ان ترسل
الكثير من المسيرات في اماكن اخرى في هذه
المنطقه في بحر جنوب الصين في سوريا في
شمال المحيط الهادئ حيث تشكل روسيا تهديدا
او قوى عسكريه معاديه اخرى تقوم بنشاطات
معاديه على العموم نستمر في متابعه اخر
تصريحات والتداعيات من الاطراف المختلفه
شكرا جزيلا لك
عضو مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه الامريكيه
وكذلك العضو في مركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه
واشكر من موسكو فيكتور
محلل سياسي والخبير في الشؤون الدوليه ومن
الدوحه العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا
لمن
[موسيقى]